what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to top five Tuesday's a
weekly series where we count down the
top 5 characters teams and concepts from
across a comic book industry as always
these lists are drawn from the top five
Tuesday section of the weekly pull form
and so if you want to have your list
featured in this video then your best
bet is to go there post your topic and
hopefully it'll get picked so this week
we're going to be counting down the top
5 Lantern Corps members in DC Comics so
coming in at number 5 on our list is
Atrocitus appearing for the first time
in rage of the Red Lanterns with the
brunt of his backstory actually coming
in the secret origin stories Atrocitus
was the first to create a Red Lantern
and form the fan-favorite group the Red
Lantern Corps a branch of the emotional
spectrum that actually focuses on rage
rather than willpower like the Green
Lantern's themselves initially being
presented as a victim of the Guardians
botched attempt to police the universe
using the Manhunters Atrocitus his
family and in fact his entire race were
eliminated by the Manhunters in the
massacre of Sector 666 leading
atrocities in such a vengeful state that
he pulled all his rage into the form of
a Red Lantern in addition to this
Atrocitus constructed the Red Lantern
ring in such a way that it actually has
the power to overcome and corrupt the
power rings of others and actually turn
them to the Red Lantern Corps themselves
the only way this can be counteracted is
by using the blue power ring of Hope now
using his newly formed Red Lantern Corps
Atrocitus actually appeared before Hal
Jordan and the Green Lantern's during
their fight with the Sinestro Corps and
brought on what I consider to be one of
the most amazing displays of ass-kicking
ever seen in DC Comics what his Red
Lantern Corps took out the Green
Lantern's and the Sinestro Corps in
order to capture Sinestro himself so at
number 4 on our list comes Jon Stewart
and I always felt like Jon Stewart just
didn't get enough love when it came to
these Lantern Corps lists so I'm adding
him into mine initially appearing and
Green Lantern vol 2 issue number 52 Jon
Stewart undertook the mantle of the
Green Lantern as a replacement for a guy
Gardner who at the time was this kind of
backup / early trainee of Hal Jordan
should Hal Jordan become incapable of
being a member of the Green Lantern
Corps
now this ultimately came to fruition and
vol 2
choose number 172 through 200 prior to
the crisis on Infinite Earths when Hal
Jordan actually vacated the role of the
Green Lantern and actually handed the
reins over to Jon Stewart himself as the
one and only Green Lantern of this
sector
now after undertaking the duties of the
Green Lantern and John Stehr approved
himself to be extremely capable in this
role and actually became a leader of
various other superhero peacekeeping
forces in the DC Universe which included
the mosaics and the dark stars but with
the 2004 Green Lantern rebirth event
what we found was that with the
guardians of the universe taking
everything back to the way it was before
and actually establishing a two-man
Green Lantern team for each section that
Jon Stewart found himself paired with
Hal Jordan as the Green Lantern team of
this sector so rounding out our list at
the number 3 spot is Kyle Rayner first
appearing during the Emerald Twilight
Saga in 1994 Kyle Rayner became a huge
fan favorite not just due to the fact
that he inherited the role of the Green
Lantern from Hal Jordan after Hal had
basically laid waste to the Green
Lantern Corps and the guardians of the
universe themselves but because Kyle
Rayner put a new spin on the Green
Lantern constructs that had never been
seen before prior to Kyle Rayner most if
not all of the Green Lantern constructs
consisted of stabbing weapons consisted
of hammers a blunt instruments of items
that could be used to deal a large
amount of damage at one time Kyle Rayner
basically changed all this he basically
changed things up he pushed the limits
of his ring by using his imagination to
create other superheroes to fight
alongside him to create futuristic
weapons and to even go as far as to take
characters that he had created for his
own comic books and bring those
characters to life to fight beside him
now due to the fact that most foes of
present and former Green Lantern's were
used to the constructs that they would
create the conflicts that would come in
with Kyle Rayner and these various foes
would present unforeseen defeats on
behalf of these foes the reason being
because they weren't used to the
constructs that Kyle Rayner would create
and in Green Lantern new guardians
number three and number four Kyle Rayner
was actually successfully able to wield
all of the Lantern rings at the same
time albeit only for a few moments
although this eventually led to him
being able to tap
the power of all of the other Lantern
cores without actually having to use
their rings now this is sort of a
permanent thing and it's actually
something he's learning to evolve
something he's learning to grow with so
coming in at number two on our list is
Hal Jordan arguably the most popular of
the Green Lantern's initially appearing
in DC showcase number 22 in 1959 Hal
Jordan was instrumental in helping DC to
revitalize interest in DC comic book
characters going into the Silver Age of
comics with Hal Jordan undertaking the
mantle of the Green Lantern and his
source of power emanating from the
central battery core in the form of his
Green Lantern itself Hal Jordan
introduced DC fans to a much larger
Green Lantern universe with thousands of
lanterns patrolling hundreds of sectors
across the universe this introduction
brought with it a vast array of new
villains which included former Green
Lantern Sinestro and the Sinestro Corps
as well as the embodiment of fear itself
parallax
now while Hal Jordan has lost his role
as the Green Lantern he's actually
gained it back and even become the
villain parallax at various points in
his run of DC Comics Hal Jordan stands
the test of time as one of the greatest
DC superheroes and possibly the best
Green Lantern to date the so with Kyle
Rayner and Hal Jordan taking the number
three and number two spots respectively
on our list I think that number one SWAT
will come as a bit of a controversial
one among Green Lantern fans and so for
the top spot what I've done here is I've
picked Allen Scott initially appearing
in all American comics number 16 in 1940
Allen Scott is the original Green
Lantern now where Hal Jordan and all
subsequent lanterns appearing in the
Silver Age of comics going forward
gained their rings as a result of the
guardians of the universe and while
their rings are established in
technology Allen scotch power ring was
initially established as a magical base
in the sense that Green was tied to the
planet itself tied to earth itself
now while Alice Goss initial use of his
ring was nowhere near the level of Hal
Jordan or even Kyle Rayner the
significance of Allen's Scott doesn't
come in the use of his ring or even the
origins of the ring itself the
significance of Allen Scott is that he
started the Green Lantern mythos without
Allen Scott there be no Hal Jordan there
would be
Ocala where there'd be no Lantern cores
or no guardians of the universe the
design of Hal Jordan as the Silver Age
Green Lantern was based on and modeled
after what it was it made Alan Scott
popular a power ring that allowed him to
achieve incredible feats combined with a
superhero archetype that have previously
been established by Superman
with that being said we're going to go
ahead and bring this video to an end and
let me know down in the comments section
what your top 5 Lantern Corps members
are or that may said I will catch you
guys later
[Music]
Oh
you